[Applause]
every time we would go eat remember on a
road mark always asks the waiter he goes
uh what's the most
ordered item on the menu no no i did the
same thing
every time i go ask and i go why you
always ask that he goes oh crowd wisdom
i know what you mean he goes it's always
right and he's got a point
if it's some fire [ __ ] here you break
down the argument what was the reason
why
yeah no basically that like that uh
crowd wisdom like there's like these
little like uh
experiment shits oh gosh he's rolling
his eyes right now no no no no no no no
no no no it's gonna be long
i'm not gonna keep it along with no no
no i swear basically like
if you have a group of people and you
have a bunch of coins in a jar and you
ask
all the people hey how many coins are in
the jar they're going to be able to no
individual person will be able to guess
as close as the average
but the average is always going to be
there the average is always the closest
thing like you apply that to
to food or whatever anything yeah
whatever the crowd like consensus is on
something i'm like yeah it's probably
what i like i mean think about if you're
a waiter and you realize
that over the thousands of people that
come to that restaurant they all get the
shrimp poppers or whatever the [ __ ] it
is it's probably the thing you need to
get
that's great and it will never fail you
literally never fail you
and i didn't even realize i used to do
that before mark
man that didn't happen i did it i did it
a different way because i just hated
going through the menus i would just
like pull up seamless or yelp or one of
those things and just look at it what
did they say but they would just say
like the oh
these are the most popular dishes and i
always get one of those i want to make
i want to make a little point about this
right sometimes
what i would do before and this is dumb
is you ask the waiter
their favorite item yes and that's what
i do and it's stupid and why is it
stupid because sometimes
they're just trying to get some [ __ ] out
of the restaurant out of the kitchen
that's one
two which is like they want to upsell
you that's what you're trying to say
right they're gonna say they're most
expensive or they just got some like we
got extra food
two right three their wisdom is not the
crowd wisdom
they could really like the steak but
everybody in the restaurant not the
majority the people that go to the
restaurant might be like oh the chicken
is way better than the steak
and when you eat there every day you
start to get tired of the thing that's
most popular that
you would love the first time you went
in there critics are waiters
and some of them are really good waiters
meaning they're they're able to
pinpoint something and say it's
absolutely delicious and we trust them
as some
piece of content if you will right but
the crowd
crowd wisdom the crowd is right do you
ever do that with like with like videos
on like facebook or something
like instagram if it's got like a ton of
views yep if it's got like
three four million views like it must be
all right i got time i'll watch a three
minute video if it's got five million
views yep
if it's got like ten thousand views
you've got a five minute video it's like
ten seconds of mine you better deliver
yeah i think we do with everything i
think that's why they put the views on
there
yeah exactly an incentive yeah yeah and
you've noticed sorry to cut your tail
but you notice even with our [ __ ] that
we put out
is once it cracks a certain number
it's actually easier to rack up views
like if we hit like one million in a
week that's what
viral is yeah 100 but like uh you would
think that like
there's an immediate viral sensation but
it also tracks faster than the other
stuff for that reason it's confirmed
what are you saying taylor well based on
like the food thing how do you know the
waiter's not just lying to you though
that's why you don't trust the waiter
but who you asking about yeah yeah the
crowd
what's the crowd take how you know he's
just going to put in his own
like favorite yeah it's true but if he
says some [ __ ] with like mushrooms in it
you know he's lying
yeah mark hates mushrooms because they
look like tiger's dead
yeah oh that's the hate
yeah is the girl jealous i'm not jealous
i don't care about mushrooms
they're not bigger than me or whatever
you think i care about mushrooms
no i just think it's the grossest food
right right right
you